le football français est en deuil
omar sahnoun est mort crise cardiaque à
24 ans teheran affrontements entre
étudiants marxistes et islamiques
plusieurs victimes
nixon à antenne 2 l'occident doit réagir
au bluff soviétique mais c'est bon soir
la mort d'un footballeur quand on a 25
ans à peine et que l'on meurt sur un
terrain d'une crise cardiaque
chacun se pose toujours beaucoup de
questions la disparition prématurée de
mars hanoune international de l'équipe
de france ancienne valeur sûre du
football club de nantes qui viennent
s'envoler ce soir pour valence et
jusqu'à cet après-midi joueurs aux
girondins de bordeaux a interloqué tous
les milieux sportifs ce n'était pas
prendre un match mais pendant une petite
séance anodine d'entraînement thierry
roland vendredi dernier bordeaux
recevait brest et personne ne pouvait
alors imaginer que le but égalisateur
réussi par les girondins allaient être
le dernier but marqué par omar sahnoun
omar sahnoun qui n'avaient pas 25 ans
est mort ce matin au cours de
l'entraînement des girondins de bordeaux
d'une crise cardiaque fils d'arc il
était né le 28 août 1955 à guy roux main
en algérie il avait gravi tous les
échelons à nantes où il joue à six ans
de 73 à 79 avant de signer en juin
dernier aux girondins de bordeaux
déjà en août 77 à l'occasion du premier
rassemblement de l'équipe de france
avant un match contre hambourg sahnoun
avait été victime d'un accident
cardiaque il devait arrêter toute
activité sportive pendant six mois avant
de reprendre l'entraînement sous
contrôle médical
s
j'y crois j'espère redémarrer je n'ai
plus je ne ressens plus rien je n'ai
aucun problème je crois que sur le
terrain à l'entraînement je le trouvais
il faut que je continue à travailler
puisque les autres parce que j'en ai
plus besoin
j'espère qu'on retrouvera au barça wind
land and comme tout sportif et un
certain nombre de sportifs de haut
niveau en particulier de footballeur au
marché nous n'était suivie au
laboratoire et par le médecin de son
club il avait eu un malaise vous en
souvenez qui avait été décrit dans la
presse en équipe de france
au retour de ce stage en équipe de
france il avait été arrêté quelques
semaines puis en accord avec son médecin
du club
il avait été autorisé à reprendre
l'activité et la compétition et il a
continué à ce moment là à jouer en
première division et en troisième
division jusqu'au mois de juin de juin
nous l'avions nous à cette époque
déclaré apte au jeu habituellement tous
les athlètes ont un être quart de gramme
de repos ont quelques petit test
d'effort avec surveillance fréquence
cardiaque et de la pression artérielle
et tous les sportifs de haut niveau ont
également une épreuve d'effort plus
sophistiqués plus intense avec bien sûr
une surveillance continue de la
fréquence cardiaque et des lettres aux
quarts des rames ce qui permet de
déceler la moindre anomalie le moindre
petit problème et à ce moment-là limiter
l'activité physique c'est justement ce
que nous faisons pour les sportifs de
haut niveau
deuxième coup de projecteur sur
l'actualité sportive ce soir lausanne
avec le début des travaux de la
commission exécutive du comité
international olympique débuts pour le
moins morose et pessimiste n'est pas
seulement l'avenir des jeux de moscou
qui va se jouer à l'issue d'une
gigantesque partie des mais l'avenir des
jeux olympiques tout court lausanne jean
marc et ma première impression est que
les membres du comité olympique
international vont chercher tous les
moyens de maintenir les jeux olympiques
à moscou en juillet prochain après la
décision américaine de boycottage la
tendance paraît être un engagement
individuel d'athlètes avec ou sans les
fédérations le comité olympique
international et les fédérations
internationales rude se réunissent deux
à ce sujet resterait bien sûr à
déterminer les critères de sélection
mais si ce principe était admis il
imposerait une modification des règles
du cio et la convocation d'une session
extraordinaire serait vraisemblablement
nécessaire ban à munich bien lieu au
directeur du cio n'a pas été très
explicite à ce sujet aujourd'hui
quant au président du comité olympique
international lord qui l'animent muet
depuis les placides mais pas inactifs a
tenu à préciser madame berlioux sa
conférence de presse est attendu pour
mercredi en fin d'après midi
rien jusqu'à présent n'a filtré de ces
éventuelles propositions
eh bien en attendant ici on fait comme
si la plupart des pays devaient
participer
deuxième gros dossier la qualité l'iran
avec des développements que nous aurons
peut-être dans le courant de ce journal
sur ce gros titre 11 morts à
l'université de téhéran un chiffre qui
n'est pas officiel qui n'est pas
confirmé mais qui vous dit assez bien
l'intensité des affrontements qui ont eu
pour théâtre cet après midi lui restait
deux terrans sont les membres des partis
de gauche qui se sont violemment heurtés
aux gardiens de la révolution et à des
extrémistes religieux tout à l'heure
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes convergeaient vers la
résidence de l'imam khomeiny qui doit
prendre la parole dans quelques minutes
le moment est grave en effet pour l'iran
et peut-être recevons nous des images
par un flash spécial vers 8h15 l'iran
dont les responsables ont gardé toute la
journée un oeil sur luxembourg c'est là
en effet que les neuf européens se sont
réunis pour décider oui ou non
d'apporter leur soutien à la
condamnation américaine et au besoin aux
sanctions de washington
les japonais sont venus à luxembourg
pour donner encore un petit peu plus de
poids à les visions les européens en
déclarant qu'ils étaient prêts à
s'aligner sur la décision des neuf
luxembourg georges bortoli flandre ne
pas prendre des sanctions contre l'iran
c'est la question qui se pose ici ce
soir aux ministres des affaires
étrangères des neuf et une question
grave en question délicate
en effet si les européens ne s'associe
pas aux sanctions contre l'iran on
pensera qu'il ne sont pas suffisamment
solidaires les américains et ça dans une
affaire où les américains est
indiscutablement le droit pour eux
puisque leur jeu tâche en retenue puis
maintenant 170 jours mais si en revanche
les européens prennent des sanctions
s'associe aux sanctions américaines
est ce que ça ne va pas risquer nos vies
mais à quoi la situation dans une région
du monde où elle est déjà terriblement
explosif c'est pour ça que les européens
doivent calculer très juste très serré
leur marge de manoeuvre est terriblement
étroite alors si il décide de mettre au
point un calendrier de sanctions disons
il faudra encore voir quel type de
sanctions est ce que fera simplement des
sanctions politiques c'est à dire un
petit peu de principes comme la
diminution des représentations
diplomatiques
ou bien est-ce que l'on prendra des
sanctions concrètes c'est à dire
économique ceci encore une deuxième
question est également une question
délicate cependant l'iran à d'ores et
déjà arrêté ces chargements de pétrole à
destination du japon et quant à la
position française je vous signale que
jean françois poncet le ministre
française a fait trop cher sera demain
l'invité de ce journal de 20 heures je
les amenais cas l'opinion commence à
gronder à la veille d importantes
primaires de pennsylvanie un spécialiste
de la cia commencent à dire que les
états unis ont toujours les moyens de
lancer un raid surprise sur l'ambassade
américaine de téhéran et la voix de
richard nixon se fait entendre un peu
plus fort richard nixon qui vous le
savez à garder c'est comme ça + crédit
en france qu'aux états unis
de là l'intérêt particulier suscité par
antenne de midi dont il était tout à
l'heure la vedette richard nixon qui
démonte tout d'abord dans la série
l'extrait que nous allons ready fusée la
conception que les soviétiques ont de la
détente mais pour les diabétiques
ils conçoivent on a des tentes seulement
comme étant un moyen qui leur permet
d'éviter la guerre du pierre
simultanément ils pensent que s'ils
peuvent continuer et ils vont le faire
d'ailleurs s'ils peuvent continuer un
niveau non nucléaires à s'étendre a
tenté de propager le communisme le
parlement dès le fond dans mes
entretiens avec les chinois et avec les
soviets
ils n'ont jamais caché la chose
ils m'ont dit ceci écoutez nous allons
tension ils ont jamais dit vous savez on
va prendre cuba la semaine prochaine il
avait déjà prises d'ailleurs
nous allons nous avons l'intention de
nous emparer de cette partie de
l'afrique de telles parties de
l'amérique latine
non bien sûr mais au cours des débats
ils ont dit à de nombreuses reprises
qu'ils n'ont pas l'intention
d'abandonner leur désir de domination
mondiale
les leaders soviétiques ne sont pas fous
et le vendre ils ne veulent pas d'une
guerre nucléaire
ils ne veulent pas risquer la discussion
que ça pourrait provoquer même avec la
puissance qui la leur mais ils veulent
le monde
ils veulent le monde sans guerre c'est
ce c'est cela qu'ils conçoivent comme
étant la détente
ce n'est pas à nous de leur permettre il
faut parler avec eux de façon à éviter
une guerre nucléaire
et quand ils sont assis comme ça avec
vous et qu'ils disent leurs projets est
ce qu'un président américain doit
reconnaître qu'il est prêt ou qu'il
serait prêt dans une situation de ce
genre à utiliser la force
est-ce qu'il faut montrer la force est
une chose qui le sert de rien lorsqu'on
parle avec les lumières soviétique
oui oui ils sont maîtres du bluff
coacher sur tu étais un bluffeur m et
briller genève non non ce n'est pas
autant enfin peu moins dix ans il était
beaucoup moins civile très rude très
énergique pas aussi rapide pas aussi vif
que khrouchtchev mais aussi intelligent
khrouchtchev
mais ce que je voulais dire c'est
suffisant on ne s'assied pas une table
avec les leaders soviétiques et on ne
leur dit pas si vous faites ceci ou tel
autre chose moi je vais réagir par
l'armement nucléaire au par une guerre
nucléaire
mais toujours ils devront savoir d'après
votre comportement que s'ils vont trop
loin dans telle ou telle direction
cela sera préjudiciable à leurs intérêts
et si c'est préjudiciable à nos intérêts
nous réagirons est dans le vrai qu'on
revienne un peu quelques instants
nourrir sur le problème de l'iran si
vous aviez été ou si vous étiez
aujourd'hui le président des états unis
auriez-vous décidé une action militaire
pour libérer les otages
adhérents et je complète est ce que
aujourd'hui
le président carter peut prendre une
décision de ce genre en iran
est ce que c'est encore possible le
moment auquel il fallait prendre les
mesures militaires le mans il fallait ne
pas léser les exclure ces mesures
militaires s'étaient tout au début la
qos
nous avons raté cette occasion je
n'aurais pas excusé h de la force je
n'aurais pas exclu usage de la force au
départ et sur le plan diplomatique il y
aurait eu probablement de très
puissantes de très vigoureuse
protestation diplomatique bien je leur
ai pris mon parti mais je serais
intervenu entre vous nous avez dit tout
à l'heure que pour vous c'était reagan
qui allait être probablement élu
président des états unis
c'est peut-être un pronostic je n'ai pas
si c'est un choix
elle est peut-être nous dire quant à
l'avenir pour cette campagne
si monsieur carter gagne une autre bonne
chance de gagner après tout c'est vous
savez ce n'est pas tellement pronostique
que je présente là mais un avis
personnel
en tout cas pas une certitude mais
postiers de monsieur carter quel que
soit le résultat des élections
s'il gagne il faudra que ce que ce soit
quelqu'un qui soit un peu plus sûr de
lui même qui soit capable de manifester
son leadership de façon à ce qu'il est -
d'ambiguïté un mot encore sur l'iran
pour vous dire que la mère du plus jeune
des otages de l'ambassade américaine a
finalement été autorisé à rencontrer
aujourd'hui son fils le sergent kevin
herning les étudiants islamiques avaient
dit oui sont venus la chercher à l'aube
dans sa chambre d'hôtel lui ont fait
visiter le cimetière où reposent des
martyrs de la révolution et lui ont fait
rencontrer donc tout à l'heure son fils
dont l'ayatollah calque ali a même
demandé la libération là encore
peut-être des images dans quatre à cinq
minutes en provenance de terre belgrade
il est prouvé qu'on pouvait aller encore
plus loin dans le pessimisme des
communiqués puisque le dernier des
bulletins de santé dit maintenant tout
simplement que la vie du prix anti tau
et menacé son état général et
particulièrement grave disent les
médecins
bruxelles le début des travaux du
conseil agricole des neuf les ministres
européens sont toujours profondément
divisée sur le niveau des prix agricoles
et sur la super taxe laitière
pub a maintenant le costa rica demande
la reprise du pont aérien avec la havane
le guen demandeurs 103 et a même fait
savoir qu'il était prêt à accueillir
autant de réfugiés que la situation le
rendrait nécessaire
deux navires venant de floride se trouve
dans un port 30 km à l'ouest de la
havane
mais on ignore encore le nombre de
réfugiés que les autorités cubaines
laisseront embarquer sur ses bâtiments à
cuba à la population toute entière a été
appelé à soutenir le symbole de la
révolution gravement altérée par la
sphère de l'ambassade du pérou et
avant-hier un million de cubains ont
défilé dans les rues de la havane mais
cette manifestation reflète elle
réellement le sentiment populaire
un reportage de bernard à et bernard
puis ce sont près d'un million de
manifestants c'est la moitié de la
havane le dixième de la population de
cuba qui est ainsi venue défiler à
l'appel des organisations de masse
c'est clair le gouvernement cubain veut
montrer à travers cette manifestation
que la population toute entière et
derrière c'est cher et c'est vrai ces
derniers jours les autorités cubaines
ont réussi un tour de force
ils sont parvenus à transformer les
réfugiés de l'ambassade du pérou qui les
gêne tant en expulser dont chacun à cuba
se réjouit du départ c'est en tout cas
ce que proclame ses pancartes
ce que crient ou ce que chante la
plupart de ces hommes ou de cette femme
dans des manifestations de ce type on a
l'impression qu'une partie très
importante de la foule qui défilent ici
le fait volontairement
elle rejette effectivement les 10000
roselyne réfugiés ont choisi de frites
esprits cela dit il y a dans cette foule
des gens qui sont là mais qui ne veulent
pas y est ils sont venus qui n'avait pas
le choix et je vous propose d'écouter le
témoignage d'un cubain c'est un haut
fonctionnaire qui a préféré pour des
raisons évidentes garder l'anonymat et
qui prouve bien qu'il existe à l'heure
actuelle à cuba dans le système
une opposition qui a beaucoup de mal à
se faire entendre mais alors pourquoi si
les gens sont tellement mécontent
pourquoi vont-ils en masse manifester
contre les réfugiés les injurier comme
ils le feront par peur pourquoi je dis
par peur parce que ils ont obligé d'y
aller
si vous êtes dans votre métier on vous
dit à travers le syndicat
à midi on va sortir on va manifester
il faut qu'on soit là si tu ne veux si
tu n'y vas pas tu te remarque simplement
mais je me demande chose ou si demain
fidel castro ouvre le port de camaret
hawke pour que de petits ou de grands
bateaux puis sortir mais familles qui
veulent quitter le pays
on pourra constater parfaitement que la
moitié des gens de ces gens qui
manifestent ne seront pas là ils seront
et ces gens là seront dans les poches
des canadiens mais demain il ya une très
grande manifestation toi tu y vas oui
bien sûr sujet pourquoi pas pourquoi oui
parce que je dois continuer à vivre un
cubain si je voulais oui et si je vais
continuer à vivre à cuba
il faut que j'y aille et je veux dire de
conscience et je vais dire des gros mots
je veux dire des choses offensive contre
ces cubains et pourquoi n'étiez pas
parti parce que je veux lutter ici deux
ans parce que je ne vois pas aucune
sortie du problème de cuba miam à miami
ou aliments ou au costa rica
la solution à deux états et par aval est
à 100 des coûts est tapi dans le rire et
à cuba
la véritable solution vous êtes beaucoup
à penser comme ça bien sûr que si ce
n'est pas une élite intellectuelle mais
qu'elle reste intellectuelle
et on va voir tu vas qu'est ce que tu
reproches à ce régime je réponds en
serre gym la quantité des mensonges
qu'ils nous ont dit ok ce régime nous a
dit au nom de la liberté au nom du
prolétariat au nom du communisme ça
c'est ça que je reproche parce que et il
faut connaître il faut vivre tous les
jours à cuba pour savoir combien de
l'absence de manque de liberté il ya
tous les jours et cela s'est traduit
dans la presse dans le métier dans la
maison dans la rue alors si tout le
monde est si fort c'est à dire par
exemple si moi je veux je voudrais dire
une vérité il faut que cette vérité soit
dix se dit très bas parce que une vérité
dit très bien quand ça coûte de peines
de prison voilà dernières nouvelles en
provenance de l'étranger reviennent me
l'apprendre en syrie assassinat de omar
awadh le membre dirigeant du parti
communiste par des membres de la
confrérie des frères musulmans
la politique française maintenant
georges marchais annoncé dans l'après
midi que le parti communiste allait
organiser un grand débat politique à
travers le pays des milliers de
rencontres auront lieu dans les
entreprises les quartiers et les
villages et à propos les différentes
affaires entre guillemets georges
marchais a ironisé sur les hommes
politiques dit il verse des larmes de
crocodile sur la dégradation des moeurs
politiques il explique pourquoi les
communistes ne participons pas à ces
séances d'auto flagellation et à ce
concert des lamentations une écoute ans
il est devenu du dernier chic parisien
chez les politiciens de proclamer bien
haut son dégoût de la politique en
mettant tous les hommes politiques dans
le même sac on rende plus fiers services
qu'ils puissent être à l'un d'entre eux
on cherche deux filles de la droite qui
peut ainsi apparaître comme étant
au-dessus de la mêlée
le président de la république voilà
derrière moi l'instant les images qui
nous arrive de teyran de madame barbe
rase
mais dont je vous disais qu'elle avait
rencontré son fils à l'ambassade
américaine et qui vous voyez amplement
et enfin de visiter le cimetière où
reposent la plupart des martyrs de la
révolution ratée rendront peu de temps
après elle rencontrait ce sont 6 madame
team je pense que vous en souvenez cette
femme qui était notre invité il y a dix
jours à peu près peu de temps avant de
se rendre pour terran et pouvoir
finalement voir aujourd'hui son fils
jean pierre fourcade de responsables des
clubs perspectives et réalités s'est
inquiété lui aussi et là je reviens à ce
que disait georges marchais du fossé qui
se creuse entre le milieu politique et
les préoccupations fondamentales des
français après le rendez vous manqué
d'il ya quelques semaines les élus
bretons vont revenir à paris après
demain pour rencontrer le chef de l'état
au centre des conversations
le risque que fait toujours courir
l'épave du tanio les travaux de
colmatage n'ont pu commencer à cause du
mauvais temps mais aussi les problèmes
d'indemnisation et les mesures
préventives à instaurer pour éviter que
pareille catastrophe ne se reproduise
face à l'épave à environ 50 km de là
roscoff philippe gassot rôles en tourtes
et on rencontrait des bretons
fataliste et désabusé pour ceux qui
vivent la ville entre des agriculteurs
bretons occupé à travailler la terre
sablonneuse de leur petite parcelle
exigu où seuls le cheval peut encore
manoeuvrait la marée noire du tanio
dernière en date et subit une fatalité
même si l'agriculteur de l'île de batz
n'a pas souffert directement de la
pollution il est solidaire des autres de
ceux qui cette fois ont décidé que la
marée noire se passerait sans eux et
qu'ils n'ont pas abandonné même
temporairement leur métier pour venir à
la rescousse
ils sont restés à leurs affaires comme
lui à ses pommes de terre ce que cette
dernière marée noire a une influence
chez les agriculteurs
ben oui point de vue agriculture non
souffler répondre le ter non mais pour
nos arquois que nous récoltons pour
l'engrais c'est le terrain
les maires des communes des côtes du
nord on dit ont repris leurs activités
dans le cadre du plan polmar mais sur
les grèves comme on dit ici pour parler
du bord de la mer
les seuls volontaires sont ceux désignés
d'office pour reprendre la plaisanterie
d'un appelé ils sont près de 3000 à
continuer la lutte
seule touche civile les tracteurs on
apprend rapidement qu'ils sont loués à
prix d'or
car dans l'île nous n'avons pas vu un
seul civil prendre une pelle ou un saut
comme s'il n'avait plus rien à voir avec
tout cela
pourtant il y à fort à faire par la
magie des courants des côtes comme celle
de roscoff sont complètement d'épargné
d'autres par contre sont devenus des
cloaques nauséabond ou de la pollution
on ne voit pas la fin
chaque clapotis la moindre petite vague
amène son quota de pétrole sur ce qui
s'appelle la grève blanche et qui a déjà
été nettoyé
aujourd'hui il faut recommencer
alors ici moins qu'avant
oh non pas de dire qu'on a des secteurs
quoi près par le secteur font
ouais saisonniers bref si vous pouviez
voir le président de la république
qu'est ce que vous lui demanderiez
rendrait entraînant des frais
supplémentaires pour les pêcheurs
la marée noire touche surtout le secteur
du tourisme
j'aime voir mon métier parce que je suis
commerçant ce qu'on accents saisonniers
comment les articles de plage à
souvenirs article ils vident à voir si
la saison est foutue ben c'est fini quoi
le plus qu'à mettre la clé sous le
paillasson
eh bien nous espérions que ça ne se
renouvellerait pas et parce qu'on nous
avait été des promesses que nous avions
été assez naïf pour y croire et l'amoco
cadiz avait été une telle catastrophe
que on s'était imaginé que les pouvoirs
publics feraient ce qu'il faut pour
essayer que de prendre des décisions
essayer que ça ne se renouvellent pas
les barrages flottants sont toujours en
place bien que leur utilité soit des
plus contestées il rassure ceux qui
s'abritent derrière et qui est épargnée
jusque-là espère que le tanio sera
neutralisée et que les boudins de
caoutchouc n'auront pas à servir
on ne se fait guère d'illusions pour
plus tard mais cette fois à nouveau les
élus locaux vont demander à être compris
et des et peut être rassuré on aura du
mal à rassurer la population en attente
prochain
parti comme sévenans ouais elle le
transport qui presque l'arche
c'est presque une évidence que
ils vont arriver à notre santé
certains
bah ça se passe donc à roscoff et juste
en face à l'île de batz cela dit sur les
zones les plus touchées c'est à dire un
coeur aux grecs et à trégastel on
travaille d'arrache-pied pour que la
zone la saison ne soit pas foutu comme
disait cet interlocuteur tout à l'heure
je pense qu'on y arrivera et puis la
bretagne est très grande et je crois que
le plus grand mal à leur faire faire aux
bretons serait de ne pas venir cet été
en bretagne depuis maintenant un mois le
métro parisien n'est plus nettoyées dans
certaines stations on assiste à la
prolifération des rats des souris et
même des vers de terre les grévistes
s'opposent à tout nettoyage effectué à
la sauvette et d'une manière générale
les 900 balayeur du métro en très grande
majorité des immigrés semble prêt à
s'installer dans une grève très dure à
reportage de dominique torrès et à la
salle 29 jours de grève pour les
nettoyants du métro après trois semaines
les grévistes ont obtenu l'autorisation
de se servir des douches et de la
cantine du personnel de la ratp locaux
dont ils effectuent d'ailleurs le
nettoyage et 14 employeurs qui sous
traite à la ratp ont accepté de passer
les nettoyeurs du métro de 2330 moins
que le smic à 2600 francs par mois et
pour l'instant les grévistes disent les
peu très peu
comment vivez vous est-ce que c'est
comment vu le bout mais on ne parle à la
mairie marry me donnait des 100 francs
maximum de 100 francs et 100 francs
sexuel même si ça convient vie privée
que sur ça c'est ça avec des familles
parfois avec des fans et les acteurs
très difficile très dj du livre et des
expressions vraiment madame on à marle
après jantes nos jours de grève
nous avons entamé les négociations avec
les patrons du nettoyage est
actuellement sur les 500 francs que
demandent les travailleurs pour arriver
à 2800 francs nets par mois
les patrons n'ont accordé actuellement
que 191 fois aller qui exactement
négocier vous concernant les conditions
de travail il m'a garanti de l'emploi
nous avons négocié avec la direction de
la ratp c'est problème la concerne est
maintenant sur les salaires nous
négocions avec les quatorze patrons des
entreprises du métro et en présence de
la direction de la ratp
selon vous qui tient les ficelles dans
cette lutte les patrons une part de
responsabilité mais la direction de la
ratp doit tirer les ficelles pas mal
aussi bien le personnel de la ratp aps
les usagers semblent en général
favorable à cause des grévistes mais au
point de vue le savez allier à présent
ils ont juste eu raison parce que vivre
avec ce qu'ils vivent c'est terriblement
difficile
faut quand même pas exagérer non plus et
en 1800 francs par mois c'est pas la mer
à boire de ce qu'ils avancent
quelques est pas normal devrait
augmenter ça me trouvais qu'ils en
vivent ah oui et non
vous les soutenez alors bien sûr
c'est normal même si c'est même si bien
qu'on vit dans la peur les inconvénients
dans pour vous pour vous usagers du
métro normal c'est obligé le métro va
être augmenté au rythme normal c'est au
courant des revendications des
nettoyeurs de métro elle n'est pas
intéressée écouter chez pas le droit de
me faire et c'est ça j'arrive de
province voire vais au travail
j'ai toujours respecté xi c'est très
désagréable pour le public évidemment
celle là
alors place à présent le conflit se
poursuit pour 230 de plus par mois
la ratp refuse de fléchir les ouvriers
tiennent bon il souligne que même avec
les 2800 francs qu'il réclame ils seront
encore payer moins beaucoup moins pour
les éboueurs de la capitale qui sont
considérés eux comme des fonctionnaires
à part entière je rappelle a aussi pour
but une augmentation des salaires mais
aussi à plus long terme une intégration
de ces personnels par la ratp
et puis le roi des gitans est mort hier
novara dans le piémont parloir nesto
régner sur près de 5000 sujet dispersés
à travers toute l'europe
la météo bien aujourd'hui le temps est
resté froid et variable généralement le
ciel a été couvert et il a plu sur l'est
il a même neigé sur les pyrénées demain
des averses seront encore observées des
ardennes et des vosges aux alpes
ailleurs des passages nuageux
alterneront avec des éclaircies
le soleil fera quelques belles
apparitions près de l'atlantique est sur
la méditerranée
voilà vous êtes de temps en temps à ses
nombreux à nous demander un rappel des
titres de l'information d'aujourd'hui à
la fin du journal le voici la mort de
marc sahnoun bowler à aux girondins de
bordeaux et qui fut international de
l'équipe de france il affrontements à
l'unité des rangs entre étudiants
islamiques et forces de gauche
certaines dépêches non confirmés parlent
de 11 morts et puis pas de décision à
lausanne à la réunion du cio
pas plus qu'à luxembourg à celle des
ministres des affaires étrangères qui
doit se réunir pour définir une position
commune quant aux sanctions à appliquer
face à l'iran ils se réunissent à
nouveau aussi bien à lausanne qu'à
luxembourg demain dans quelques minutes
vous n'allez pas rendez vous avec
question de temps comme tous les lundis
mais j'avais qu'une émission de jacques
ertaud qui vous relatera à l'expédition
française dans l'himalaya qui avait pour
but l'ascension du k2 et puis c'est paul
amar qui vous présentera le dernier
journal aux environs de 23 heures demain
notre édition de 12h45 aura pour invité
jean boissonnat voilà ce journal est
maintenant terminée bonsoir à tous et à
demain jean boissonnat de l'expansion
bien sûr